stellst dem video rein gucken zwei leute
hast acht stunden vor gewissen toll
macht meinen stücken zweites weit so
spaß macht hey was geht ab willkommen
bei einem neuen video und zwar wurde ich
vom lieben moritz bad zum youtube text
und dann sieht das nominiert und ich
finde ich ehrlich gesagt richtig cool
weil er hat das in seinem video auch so
ziemlich auf dem ball der ball das
einfach mal in der video beschreibung
es geht halt um die fragen die man als
youtuber immer mal wieder von seinen
zuschauern gestellt bekommt wie zum
beispiel wann und wie das mit youtube
anfang und so weiter und ich würde sagen
wir legen direkt mal los und ja wenn
solche fälle geben doch nach oben und
jetzt viel spaß mit dem video ja so die
erste frage ist die die ich gerade auch
schon erwähnt habe und zwar wann und
wieso hast du mit youtube angefangen
diese frage wurde mir echt schon so oft
gestellt und ja es war einfach ich kann
mich ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr genau
daran erinnern
ich habe irgendwie früher mal das und
das gemacht so videos so computerspielen
vorgestellt da war ich zwölf oder so ich
hab's glaub ich auch schon mal ein video
erwähnt und irgendwie habe ich das dann
du verleitet mal im reallife video zu
machen das hat mir gut gefallen und dann
hab ich irgendwie mal meinen alten kanal
eröffnet und jetzt ist es halt dieser
hier geworden und fand ich war so eine
ziemlich gute entscheidung weil ich mir
jetzt echt gar nicht mehr vorstellen
könnte ohne so dass einmal in der woche
zu machen also ein video für euch zu
produzieren das wäre irgendwie anders
als sonst weil ich es halt schon seit
einem jahr mache so die zweite frage ist
wie bist du auf deinen youtube namen
gekommen
die feier wird mir auch andauernd
gestellt und die meisten haben da
natürlich auch seine vermutung und
liegen auch aufrichtig und zwar ihr
könnt ihr empfehlen im stimmt alle
diesen blockbuster also dat wat am
sonntag oder samstagabend kommen was ein
toller film sein soll ist es manchmal
manchmal auch nicht und da habe ich mir
gedacht komm du willst blogs machen also
videos in hände über themen reden indem
du die zuschauer ein bisschen mit dem
irgendwo hin oder so habe ich mir machst
du doch aus dem block einfach im block
und ak
blockbuster raus und ich mit den damen
ist jetzt eigentlich immer noch ganz
okay ihr könnt ja mein kommentar
schreiben wie findet ihr das wirklich
echt interessieren und schreibt seine
kommentare jetzt kommen wir zur nächsten
frage und zwar lauten hattest du ein
vorbild also mit youtube angefangen hast
hast du jetzt ein vorbild das wird mir
nicht ganz so oft gestellt und als ich
mit youtube angefangen habe da hab ich
glaube ich kein volk ab weil darauf
überhaupt noch nicht viele leute dieses
youtube gemacht haben ihr müsst euch
vorstellen das war vor wenn ihr 17 das
war mit 12 5 jahren oder so da habe ich
das erste video hochgeladen
vielleicht war mein vorbild da irgend so
ein game netz player der heute aber
total unbekannte sich kann es eigentlich
sagen wie ich mich dazu inspirieren
konnte das zu machen aber keine ahnung
und jetzt um ehrlich zu sein habe ich
auch gar keine vorbilder die so das
machen was ich mache ich versuche
bestmöglich mein eigenes ding
durchzuziehen und am liebsten was zu
machen was vorher noch nicht so viele
gemacht haben das geht bei manchen text
zwar nicht aber ich hab' ich habe mich
so auf der schiene über von videos
dieses ganze album junge mädchen geht
und da versuche ich das so weiter
fortzusetzen weil das halt mal gut
ankommt und und ich glaube darauf ist
auch meine zielgruppe sohn ziemlich
spezialisiert und deswegen macht
natürlich spaß
die vierte frage wie lange brauchst du
um ein video fertig zu stellen
ja das ist eigentlich bei mir geht das
drehen immer relativ schnell es kommt
ganz darauf an was für video ist so wenn
ich ein video über wenig praktisch
alleine video mache dann brauche ich
eine halbe stunde sag ich mal weil ich
mich natürlich sehr verspreche dann ist
beim und trocken da muss ich irgendwann
trinken damit es wieder einigermaßen
habe ich wieder schnell gehen kann und
wenn ich ein video mit dem komiker mit
meiner freundin machen dauert auch schon
mal länger weil wir dann halt die ganze
zeit lachen und video drehen es mal ihr
müsst euch das weiß man dass es echt
witzig ist halt das ganze rum kommt und
steige ich noch mal so eine stunde bis
zwei stunden und platz dann hoch also
ich sag mal so im durchschnitt
zweieinhalb bis vier stunden höchsten
kannst du dir vorstellen youtube ist ins
hohe alter zu machen ich weiß nicht weil
stelle ich mir vor ich bin sagen wir mal
30 dann glaube ich ist meine zielgruppe
die die meine videos jetzt gucke sind
dann auch schon 25 und die interessieren
sich dafür
was nicht mehr also ich werde natürlich
so weit vorn wie es halt möglich ist und
natürlich auch den containern so zu
verändern dass das ist mir noch spaß
machen dass eure leute gucken weil
ehrlich gesagt als kleine leute wollen
da kann mir keiner sage es jetzt so
viele sagen ja ich hab so viel spaß hat
hier ihr könnt mir eine stellten video
rein gucken zwei leute hast acht stunden
vor gesessen
toll ja macht man bestimmt noch ein
zweites wald so spaß macht und die
letzte frage ist welche tipps hast du
für die die auch mit youtube anfangen
wollen da krieg ich auch so viele
nachrichten ja wie hast du es jetzt
geschafft in sehr kurzer zeit so viele
abonnenten dazu zu bekommen und kann es
mal bei mir vorbeischauen tipps zu geben
und ich kann eigentlich keinen tipp
geben weil früher als ich meinen alten
kanal noch hatte da war es relativ
einfach am anfang an abonnenten zu
kommen aber heutzutage ist es so es ist
wirklich extrem schwer und ich kann euch
eigentlich nur raten so wie es bei mir
geklappt hat ihr müsst euch ein thema
suchen wo ihr denkt jahres gucken die
leute auf jeden fall wodurch dann
vielleicht mein glück gehabt dass ein
video einfach mal 100.000 aufrufe
bekommt das hatte ich auch das glück das
halt mehrere videos unter gelegt wurde
dadurch kann man diese abonnent
natürlich hat auch zustande und ja denkt
euch irgendwas cooles aus natürlich ist
heutzutage auch eine menge glück dabei
und mehr kann ich dazu eigentlich gar
nicht sagen seid auf jeden fall sehr
natürlich es gibt auch so viel liefern
stellen sich einfach so da merkt man
nee lass es lieber direkt und und das
war ein zwar so schnell die frage
natürlich muss jetzt auch noch drei
leute nominieren oder gar ihn nachher
wie nehme ich denn man muss mal kurz
einen cut machen so ich habe jetzt
gerade mal nachgeschaut und warte ich
zum einen den mars fällt dann auf dem
technik und als drittes noch kräftig
feiern sein neues album geben wie total
ihr könnt dem abschicken
falls ich noch nicht gesehen habt oder
falls es noch nicht gehört habe besser
gesagt ich habe keine ahnung ob mir das
video sieht falls ja wäre auf jeden fall
cool und ansonsten wenn es euch gefallen
lassen auf jeden fall nach oben da und
hier ist mein instagram profil
eingebildet 430 genauso hier auf der
linken seite geht es weiter
doch linke seite geht es weiter mit
meiner freundin seine app challenge und
hier auf der rechten seite mit meinem
letzten tag keine ahnung hat das war mal
vorbeischauen und abonnieren
wenn ihr nicht verpassen wollen wir
sehen uns dann am samstag wieder und ich
kriege fast keine luft mehr weil ich so
viele zähler auf jeden fall brachte